madeleine et sébastien bonsoir
infaillible collègues de nos chefs des
chefferies de nos bureaux parlementaire
à ottawa et à québec par l'immigration
dans un premier temps il y en a été
question à ottawa d'abord et avant tout
écoutons justin trudeau soir par
labrecque
l'immigration est la clé de la reprise
économique à court terme et de la
prospérité à long terme et c'est
exactement la raison pour laquelle le
plane présente une vision visant à
augmenter un peu nos chiffres chaque
année au cours des trois prochaines
années
bon vous avez compris cette fois justin
trudeau qui s'étaient déguisés à
monsieur mendocino c'était bel et bien
monsieur inde et chine ont donc le
ministre de l'immigration madeleine et
qui annonçait donc c'est quoi un peu
plus d'un million d'immigrants trois ans
pour ottawa c'est la cible en fait il ya
une augmentation quand même assez
substantielle pour l'an prochain lorsque
les cibles avaient été communiquées à au
moins de mars dernier pour lé en 2021
on s'attendait à voir trois cent
cinquante mille nouveaux arrivants alors
que finalement ces cinquante mille de
plus qui est annoncée aujourd'hui donc
ça tourne autour de 400 milles et c'est
l'argument économique qu'ont fait valoir
avec en l'assumant totalement au début
du premier mandat de justin trudeau le
gouvernement avait mandaté tout un panel
d'experts pour essayer de trouver des
solutions à moyen long terme avoir une
croissance plus importante de l'économie
et l'immigration avait été nommé en
exemple avec des cibles encore plus
important et à l'époque c'est comme si
le gouvernement avait été prudent en
disant bon il y avait le ministre de
l'immigration à l'époque le job mais car
l'homme qui avait dit c'est pas tout le
monde au pays que la même vision
au sujet de l'immigration et le
gouvernement avait pas voulu aller aussi
loin que c'est comme si maintenant on
s'assume et je vois deux facteurs
peut-être qui contribua au fait
s'assumer autant et d'avoir une
augmentation des cibles premièrement il
ya la cac qui elles aussi commencent à
augmenter à nouveau ses cibles et
deuxièmement on a un nouveau chef du
parti conservateur et renom tour lui a
déjà dit dans une entrevue
moi j'ai toujours combattu les voix qui
disait que l'immigration était un
problème parce qu'elle va nous tous il
croit aussi que l'immigration fait
partie de la recette pour avoir une
croissance économique donc ça permet au
gouvernement d'avoir vraiment les
coudées franches et d'augmenter les
cibles sébastien oui puis au québec bon
j'ai ralenti un peu avec l'année de la
coved mais après ça ça reprend un peu
l'enjeu économique est extrêmement
important dans l'émulation avec des
pénuries de main d'oeuvre quand
l'économie va se remettre à rouler
il va rester cette pénurie de main
d'oeuvre il y aura pas nécessairement
plus de travailleurs qui seront sur le
marché donc on a besoin de l'immigration
a fait beaucoup de gens s'entendent pour
dire que la pénurie de main-d'oeuvre la
recette passe pour la combattre la
recette passe par l'immigration on a
comme pas le choix est-ce qu'on peut
mieux les intégrer c'est un peu ça la
question qu'on se pose ici à québec avec
les gouvernements de la coalition avenir
québec
à partir du moment où on accueille des
immigrants comment s'assurer qu'il reste
qu'ils s'intègrent qui deviennent des
forces vives de la communauté québécoise
il y avait des questions là-dessus la
caq à son approche
les libéraux avaient une approche
différente mais donc on se sentant et
comme un début de consensus sur le fait
qu'on a besoin de l'immigration pour
l'économie québécoise est encore faux
cils les accueillir parce que les
frontières sont quand même pas vraiment
terme et il ya les bureaux d'immigration
qui fonctionnent pas à pleine capacité
et la solution qu'ottawa évoque pour le
moment et je pense qu'à québec on a un
peu le même discours c'est de
privilégier les gens qui sont déjà au
canada comme par exemple les les
étudiants étrangers il est travailleur
temporaire aussi comme si ces gens qui
sont déjà ici donc on peut traverser des
frontières pourraient devenir des
canadiens qui pourrait tout à fait
s'intégrer à la société canadienne mais
là pour ce qui est des modalités de tout
ça du programme
tous sont pas encore arrêtées ils ont
déjà aux racines et d'une certaine façon
veste et travail où il étudie donc ils
ont une vie au pays déjà bref y ait une
convergence des messages en partie entre
ottawa et québec ce qui faisait en a
plus beaucoup dans les deux là dessus
oui mais il ya encore toute la question
des pouvoirs en immigration saussard
viager et voyez-vous lorsque le nouveau
chef du parti conservateur je vous en
parlais il ya un instant lui il parle
pas des cibles mais il ouvre la porte à
accorder plus de pouvoirs en immigration
à québec
donc c'est surtout là dessus finalement
puisque le débat québec ottawa puisse
faire de la question des cibles qui est
souvent problématique ou des coûts des
pouvoirs donc le québec contrôler ces
immigrants économiques mais ne contrôle
pas c'est la réunification familiale ne
contrôle pas non plus l'accueil des
réfugiés ça c'est ottawa qui s'en charge
mais il ya quand même entre québec et
ottawa une entente sur l'immigration qui
date d'il ya plusieurs années et à
ottawa ont 17 ans tu as
là elle est généreuse pour québec donc
si on rouvre cette entente la town dit
toujours bon êtes vous sûr que ça vous
tente de faire ça parce qu'en ce moment
les transferts qui se font de québec et
d'ottawa vers québec ne peuvent jamais
diminué peu importe le nombre
d'immigrants donc ottawa dit mayence et
peut-être à votre avantage cette entente
là et vous voulez vous vraiment la
rouvrir
donc c'est le genre de discours qu'on
entend lorsqu'il est question des
pouvoirs en immigration avec des échos
en coulisse bien sûr parlons maintenant
de la liberté d'expression il y en a
encore été question aujourd'hui par le
biais cette fois ci c'est vrai justin
trudeau qui s'est exprimé sur la
question avec évidemment en toile de
fond ce qui s'est produit en france
ces trajets que des vêtements que l'on
connaît couton justin trudeau nous
allons toujours défendre la liberté
d'expression
c'est une c'est un droit protégé dans
nos chartes des droits et libertés c'est
une valeur et un principe fondamental
pour toute société libre et nous allons
toujours la défense mais la liberté
d'expression n'est pas sans limite on
n'a pas le droit par exemple de crier au
feu dans un cinéma bondé de monde alors
on voyait rapidement sur cette question
madame et monsieur trudeau ici qui va à
l'encontre du message par exemple de son
homologue français emmanuel macron qui
disait répété cette semaine
nous ne céderons rien oui et c'est pour
ça que justin trudeau a été questionné
aujourd'hui encore parce qu'il l'a été
hier et il a été questionné
spécifiquement depuis deux jours sur les
caricatures de mohammed à savoir est ce
qu'il y a des limites justement à la
liberté d'expression est ce qu'il est
possible en occident de se moquer par
exemple de la religion et justin trudeau
hier n'a pas répondu spécifiquement à
cette question là et il a donc été
questionné à nouveau aujourd'hui sachant
que emmanuel macron lui dit bon on ne va
pas on ne va pas renoncer aux
caricatures c'est ce qu'il a dit donc
justin trudeau lui ne veut pas aller là
ne veut pas se prononcer là dessus en
disant oui la liberté de d'expression
mais aussi le respect on vit dans une
société pluraliste
il faut faire attention
on l'a portée de nos propos à la portée
de nos gestes et c'est ce qu'il a voulu
dire aujourd'hui dans en s'exprimant
peut-être un peu plus clairement qui
errent en parlant de la liberté
d'expression mais en disant qu' elle
n'est pas sans limite clarté qui est
nécessaire mais on sent bien qu'il peut
difficilement aller au delà de ça
sébastien et puis il dit aussi quand il
a été question de monsieur pâtit le wild
a convoqué il le dit il faut aussi
établir une un dialogue avec les
communautés musulmanes avec les
représentants des musulmans ici au pays
pour bon évidemment condamné ces
personnes ne peut pas condamner ce qui
s'est passé avec les attentats mais il
ajoute aussi une même phrase ou presque
qu'il faut établir des dialogues avec
les communautés ça peut être d'établir
un dialogue mais il faut dénoncer de
façon ferme
il ya des gens qui laissait entendre que
peut-être que monsieur le monsieur
trudeau avait comme pas hésité
nécessairement mais j'avais pris un
certain temps avant qu'il dénonce de
façon offert l'ouest donc il se
retrouvait dans une situation où il
devait clarifier sa position évidemment
sur ce sujet oui et d'ailleurs depuis
deux jours ils dénoncent fermement tout
acte de violence tout acte terroriste en
disant que ça absolument pas sa place et
en disant aussi que ça n'a aucun lien
avec la religion musulmane ce n'est pas
l'islam que d'avoir des actes violents
ont des actifs
voilà qui clarifie son message et des
partages un peu les choses
on va parler de kobe depuis ce qu'il le
faut et de ce défi 28 jours sébastien
qui se poursuit on le sait dans les
zones rouges au québec et ça concerne
pas mal de monde dans la province on va
parler plus parlant de cette stratégie
dans quelques instants mais coûtant tour
à tour messieurs legault est dû mais
pour l'instant je pense les probabilités
sont savoir prendre quatre semaines
si jamais on est capable de faire
quelque chose après deux ou trois
semaines
ben on va le faire en un système de
santé qui est tellement fragile espoir
que lorsqu'on roule à peu près 5 150
hospitalisations
cette semaine puis on a réussi à
contrôler entre 800 et 1000
imaginez vous si on était à de lui même
je tiens à préciser que ce thème mardi
donc ces deux extraits qu'on vous
présente sébastien parlons un peu de
cette stratégie
kiki qu'on prolonge finalement le
gouverneur et choix ils avaient le choix
de dire on part sur le rouge et avec des
mesures sanitaires assez draconiennes
pour une période indéterminée il a fait
le choix plutôt de fixer un échéancier
deuxième défi de 28 jours qu'on a
commencé hier en passant on nous disait
on va au bout de deux semaines on va
réévaluer si les indicateurs sont à la
baisse on pourrait peut-être assouplir
certaines mesures au bout de 28 jours on
verra où on en est mais le but c'est de
faire baisser des indicateurs quels
indicateurs le nombre de cas évidemment
qui a atteint un plateau mais on veut
faire baisser le nombre de cas mais au
506 que monsieur legault avait laissé
entendre pour ouvrir les restaurants les
bars paribas mais les restaurants des
cinémas et les théâtres notamment depuis
peut-être les jim on veut baisser le
nombre d'hospitalisations aussi alors on
donne espoir c'est ça que le
gouvernement a décidé d'utiliser comme
stratégie de donner un échéancier qui
fixe un espoir que ça va mieux aller au
bout de 28 jours mais pendant la semaine
après ça on ne le dit et le mois de
novembre on va être extrêmement
important on rentre à l'intérieur c'est
bien c'est qu'à l'intérieur la maladie
peut se propager
c'est un test le monde novembre donc on
est quand même cohérent avec le 28 jours
mais monsieur fall che aux états unis a
dit l'épidémiologiste en chef fathi
retour à la normale pas avant 2022 donc
leur gouvernement ou sidi ben c'est pas
qu'au moins de juin prochain on va être
de retour et dans une normale donc c'est
comme si on sait on doit s'habituer à
faire des efforts un coup de frein pour
les 28 prochains jours mais faut pas
s'attendre non plus à ce que au bout si
28 jours il ya un retour à la vie
normale à l'hiver va être plate didot il
faut être plate et justin trudeau lui
avait une autre stratégie en fait en
disant bon peut-être que dans l'europe
plusieurs régions du pays
ça va être difficile d'avoir des
rassemblements familiaux à noël donc lui
ce qu'il avait voulu faire cette semaine
c'est de se placer au diapason de la
population qui a l'impression finalement
que c'est difficile mais ce qu'on
m'indique c'est qu'il n'y a pas d'état
de panique quand même au gouvernement
fédéral face aux chiffres qu'on voit
face au nombre de cas qu'on voit en
disant bon on connaît mieux le virus que
lors de la première vague
il ya des mesures
de santé publique qui sont connus aussi
avec leurs marques avec la distanciation
sociale donc oui il y à une augmentation
des cas au pays et on avait eu droit
aujourd'hui nous à ottawa à de nouvelles
projections pour les prochaines semaines
mais c'est quand même pas l'état de
panique mais distant mais quand même on
demande à l'ensemble la population
canadienne de réduire du car les
contacts sociaux comme quoi une forme
quand même d'inquiétude il ya une forme
de réalisme car elle tend voilà en
voyant les chiffres et disant que en ce
moment un cas d'infection en contamine
en moyenne plus que 1
et ça ça ne fait pas réduire la pandémie
il ya une augmentation de la courbe dans
ce temps là donc ce que dit le les
experts de la santé publique c'est qu'il
faut encore réduire nous nos contacts
sociaux que ce soit des contacts
individuels ou des contacts collectif là
les mesures collectives ça fonctionne
les mesures individuelles aussi donc
c'est des deux côtés finalement qu'il
faut agir
c'est ce qu'on a entendu aujourd'hui les
expériences envie et cet appel là de
réduire du car nos contacts qu'il avait
été lancée il ya une semaine par le
gouvernement ici à québec
dans la même lignée de réduire les
cordages devions donc d'éviter de
ralentir la propagation de la maladie
on va on va vous laisser le mot de la
fin sébastien sur un sujet que je sais
que vous tient à coeur mais forcément la
pandémie fait ombrage porte ombrage à
toutes sortes de choses qui se passe
politiquement parlant
parlons rapidement fait tribune monsieur
les tribunes ici au québec la ministre
qui était blanc mai par la commissaire à
l'éthique
oui blâmé pour avoir entretenu ou permis
un ami qui est aussi le bédéiste
d'entretenir une relation assez serré
avec lui de contact pour vendre des
projets comme si les amis de monsieur
fait given avait peut-être un accès plus
privilégiés au ministre alors il n'y a
pas une malversation mais disons que il
ya un manquement au code d'éthique l'a5
sont recommandées par la commissaire à
l'éthique c'est 2 c'est une réprimande
une petite note oddo cie a pas beaucoup
de conséquences les s'il a plus et à
moins sévère en fait il lui clémente des
sanctions que le commissaire à l'éthique
peu recommandé que l'assemblée nationale
peut adopter c'est jusque dans la trame
narrative à procès où la caractérisation
de monsieur physique est bonne ça envoie
encore l'image prix partie de poissons
sauter là dessus qu'il est apolitique
avec une même la même approche qu'il
avait dans le monde des affaires c'est à
dire que
il a beaucoup d'amis chaque fois vous
parler de quelqu'un avec qui monsieur
fête cubaine a eu un contact on a
l'impression que c'est un ami alors un
réseau de contacts et très très élargie
il se voit lui même comme un démarcheur
pour faire fonctionner l'économie
québécoise
alors il se place dans ces situations là
parfois où il peut y avoir un parent ans
de conflit d'intérêts sans tout ça merci
beaucoup je vous souhaite un bon week
end un bon repos avant une grosse
semaine chargé la semaine prochaine